enough even though I have a daughter in
Helsinki so I say welcome dear Petri
deara most welcome to um to Stockholm
and thank you both for being here and
not least thank you Ura for accepting
our common invitation and once again
thanks for very rewarding cooperation
during the Swedish presidency I really
appreciated your handson leadership
thank you last year when urula was here
uh in Sweden we actually visited the
Space Port S range in kiruna I don't
think you have forgotten
that uh that is mainland eu's first
facility for launching satellites and
last night
at 10:00 and I think 1051 or something
1049 we were both watching I guess um
Marcus vant the Swedish astronaut um
went to space and all of Sweden is very
very proud of of what he is doing for
all of us right now today we have been
discussing uh the big strategic issues
on the EU agenda uh or perhaps how to
make EU safer Greener and Freer as we
used to put it during the presidency on
security EU support Ukraine must remain
robust substantial and long term for as
long as it
takes uh countries like Sweden and like
Finland are among those countries who
fully understand that geography matters
in
geopolitics February 1st we will meet
again in the European Council to try to
reach a United decision on Europe's
long-term economic support to Ukraine to
be able to keep a strong us commitment
it's obvious that also the EU needs to
stay very firm and
committed today we also discuss the
European competitiveness and the green
transition and
Forestry forestry makes EU stronger and
more resilient and more prepared to
tackle the combination of climate
related
problems but forestry also boosts our
competitiveness by providing sustainable
raw materials renewable energy and is
important part of the highly inovative
industry in Sweden and in Finland so
allow me briefly to make the Swedish
case forestry stands for around 10% of
all Swedish exports along with Finland
that's more than other countries in the
union forestry is also one of the core
industrial competencies that make both
Sweden and Finland role models in the
green transition we can deliver what
most countries cannot
we strongly support European cooperation
and we do believe in Level Playing
Fields but we also know that there is no
one size pits all when it comes to
forestry the preconditions for forestry
in different member states are simply
too
diverse renewable materials from
forestry provide fossil-free
Alternatives we saw this very firsthand
today during our visit to the
biomaterials in ation Lab at the Swedish
Finnish company stura enu they
demonstrated wood-based alternatives to
graphite in battery production thereby
combining forestry with Cutting Edge
technology for electrification this is
big Sweden is ready to do our part in
reaching the climate goals obviously but
to do so we need EU policy that supports
this development
the regulatory framework needs to
acknowledge sustainable forestry as an
asset in the green
transition I hope the discussions we've
had today can provide a foundation for
future EU policy for example in the
upcoming strategic agenda uh for the
next term every member state in the EU
obviously has its own core competencies
earned sometimes since century IES
forestry is one of ours so once again
thanks for today's constructive
discussions and I look forward to
continue them over to you
pet thank you so much and good
[Music]
afternoon I'm very happy to be here in
Stockholm with my good colleague prime
minister ulp and with the commission
president urula V liion thank you so
much you have had time to come
here uh we had an extensive discussion
on the future of the European Union
competitiveness security Ukraine and bio
bioeconomy I think this meeting
underlines our unity and strong
resolve to solve the common challenges
we are
facing first on
Ukraine we need to keep our level of of
ambition to meet Ukraine's military and
defense needs at EU level Ukraine must
stay a strategic
priority we need to approve the funds
for Ukraine and keep a commitment of
multi-year military
assistance we need to strengthen the
capacity of the European Defense
industry and ramp up production of
ammunation Finland has recently made the
decision to double our ammunation
production we have seen what Russia has
done in Ukraine by attacking against
independent
nation but I don't see any immediate
military threat from Russia against
Finland we in Finland sleep peacefully
at night because we are well
prepared however all EU and NATO member
states will also need to prepare
themselves from any possible
scenario on the future of the EU Finland
thinks that the main priorities for the
next commission should be strengthening
Europe's strategic
competitiveness and improving
comprehensive Security in Europe
strategic competitiveness means
improving the economic Pace Building A
more Dynamic single Market based on the
free movement Fair competition and
better ability to conclude trade
deals comprehensive security means
building up security and defense defense
industry external relations and having
stronger partnership to respond to
Global
challenges we also need stronger
external
borders Finland also
proposes creation of EU preparedness
union we need to be better prepared for
future
crisis
thirdly promoting a clean transition and
opportunities for the bioeconomy and
circular economy should be our
priorities this means being a global
front runner in clean
energy here we underline technology
neutrality sustainable bioeconomy is a
solution to many topical and Global
problems biobased product s are
renewable and it is possible to produce
them sustainably in Europe as we have
seen today in our visit in
stur this is why bioeconomy should be an
integral part of the eu's industrial
policy finally as WF said this meeting
highlights our important Nordic
cooperation and our strength when we act
together thank you thank you so much
thank you very much dear olol and dear
pety for having me here today and indeed
it was an excellent meeting and uh let
me focus on one of the most important
issues we had a wide range of issues but
I'll focus on a few
one in one month from now it will be two
years since Russia launched its terrible
war of aggression against Ukraine and we
have stood by Ukraine since day
one and we will continue to do so
crucial is for Ukraine support not only
Military Support this is also very
important but also economic support and
we discussed indeed the upcoming special
European Council where we aim to find an
agreement uh for the 50 billion Euro for
Ukraine for the next four years because
this would provide Ukraine with
predictable economic and budgetary
assistance and underline our strong
support support for
Ukraine Russia's Invasion has also been
a wake up call for Europe we have to
rethink our own defense and defense
industrial base and we must ramp up our
defense industrial base this will not
only give us more access to the
necessary military systems but it will
of course also improve very much the
interoperability of the Armed Forces uh
of the different member states in the
European Union and Finland and Sweden
are both experienced and very reliable
Partners in defense Sweden for example
is a world leader in defense industry
Finland is as we've just heard also a
Pioneer in the concept of civil defense
and we exchange views and on what we can
learn from this for the European level
so thank you very much for that in March
the commission will present a defense
industrial strategy we also discussed
European competitiveness it's one of the
big topics uh on our agenda and of
course in 2024 we must and will continue
to strengthen our economy to adapt to
the continuous changes that we see they
are well known the challenges the impact
of climate change the gamechanging
technological developments like
artificial
intelligence the need for new skills
just to name a few of the challenges
of course we have to build on our
strength and one of our core strengths
is our single market and the power of
European
Innovation and this morning I could see
it firsthand at stora Ana this Center is
really exemplary for the potential of
the
bioeconomy that is in other words to
replace fossil based materials by
biobased
ones and this is key now in many sectors
from the batteries to the electric
vehicles from gunpowder to packaging a
wide range of possibilities and these
were only a few that I was
mentioning this
Innovation will drastically reduce our
carbon footprint and on top and that's
very important it will reduce our
dependency on critical raw materials on
countries outside the European
Union so in nutshell biotech is shaping
Europe's future and it was very
impressive for me to see and to listen
to the facts and figures again proving
the strength of the forest industry in
Finland and in Sweden very important for
Finland and Sweden but also very
important for the European Union and
basically uh for all of us because it's
for uh the sanity of uh the planet un um
unconditionally
important innovation is key to our
competitiveness but of course a lot more
needs to be done I just want to mention
uh the need to finalize a deep and
liquid European Capital Market to make
sure that these innovators we were just
talking about have also access to
Capital or take for example the
strengthening of our supply chains here
to diversify and to conclude trade
agreements so that we reduce our
dependencies
and of course as I said we need to
continue improving the skills of our
Workforce final topic I want to
mention is uh migration it was a huge
step forward that we were able to agree
on The Pact on migration and Asylum this
pact sets the rules to manage migration
in the European Union based on
solidarity and on Fair sharing of
responsibilities
and The Pact gives us the means to
better secure the control of our
external
borders most recently Finland suffered
from instrumentalization of migrants
orchestrated by Russia so this is yet
another form of hybrid
Warfare and this required requires a
clear and determined response Finland
has acted
decisively and you can rely on the
European Union to support your efforts
at the same time we're working with
countries of origin of migration and
transit to tackle illegal migration and
here we want to be very clear we have
always fulfilled our International
obligations we have done that in the
past we do that today we will do it in
the future but it is Us in Europe who
decide who comes to the European Union
and under what circumstances and not the
Smugglers and traffickers or even
autocrats so Olf um and P thank you very
much for the excellent meeting and lots
of good work ahead of us thank you so
much Ula please questions yes we open up
the floor for some questions we start
with the first
row yes hello thank you P gber from
Swedish daily dog thank you for doing
this at first a question to the Prime
Minister christon please
uh what measures are your government
taking when when planning to ensure that
Sweden will meet the requirements when
it comes to the carbon storage according
to the Lulu CF uh regulation and and I
know that this mil Awards ban are will
present its report in December but since
the regulation in practice starts
already in 2026 isn't it necessary to
already today uh start to act to reach
the net storage please and for uh
president fion uh in Finland and Sweden
the main party see Forest politics
that's very much on an national issue H
why do you think it's important to take
decision of forest p on European level
and also what do you expect from Finland
and Sweden to contribute to this Forest
policy and we also met people from Green
Peace outside here why aren't you
meeting the environmental organizations
why why you here and finally please
yesterday the snd announced their lead
candidate for the upcoming uh elections
and I wonder will you run for a second
term I start with all the less exciting
questions
okay well obviously as you say I mean
there is an is a national issue in this
sense very nationally anchored uh topic
not least in Sweden and Finland I mean
goes without saying but we also
acknowledge that um forestry is a part
of of of the future climate policies I
mean and that is as we always say in in
all other um in other uh aspects that
this is a common issue uh you can only
fight climate change if you do it u in a
United in joint in a joint way and that
goes for forestry as well but we have
tried today is actually to try to to um
to describe that forestry is not only a
National Asset in terms of employment in
terms of of of of very big national
income but also a very big part of the
solution to climate related problems uh
replacing fossils for example uh but
also in very many other aspects as a
carbon sink obviously but also the fact
that uh cultivating forestry is also a
way of increasing the capacity of being
a car sink so there are many aspects to
this and the formal answer to your
question is obviously that the wonderful
swed English word m Bing and don't even
try to make me translate that but that m
m breing is the place where we have all
this discussion going on and I'm not
saying we would be United in all aspects
but that is the place for for the
Swedish position to be to be to be
anchored I think there other questions
go to you as well yes uh thank you so
much so first of all um you know that
there is an application time at EP and
this lasts till the 21st of February if
I'm well informed so we have to be
patient till then um now on the very
important uh topic um of the forestry
indeed Europe is covered with vast and
very different forests from the Northern
Forest to the Mediterranean forest for
example and of course they are very
different and they need very different
management but we can all benefit from
The Learning Experience from these
different types of forests we have all
over uh the European union now what the
northern forestry is concerned Sweden
and Finland are uh extraordinary the
home of extraordinary vast forests of
course you know that better than me and
this makes you uncontested experts in
the European Union when it comes to
Forest
policies and uh we had very a very
constructive time of um dialogue and
exchange of facts and figures in the
last months and this shaped also the
development of the legislation in the
European Union this is the way how it
has to be that we exchange knowledge on
the European level but from the member
states a lot of input uh for example as
you know um there's no one who better
you know better than anyone else uh the
importance of the high quality data
um that we need for forests to make use
of the monitoring Technologies to be
able uh to have a monitoring for um for
management of the forest and this is um
how we presented the forest management
um uh monitoring um in last uh winter it
was very much shaped by the input that
came from uh the Swedish and the Finnish
experience this is I think the way it
has to be the monitor in itself is um on
the member states level this is also
very important but the accumulation of
data on the European level helps us not
only to collect the data but also to
make them publicly available for example
for startups for example for research uh
for example for companies who want to
work with it so the principle is here uh
the monitoring itself and uh the
collection of data um at the member
state level
aggregation at the European level to
make it available to a wider public a
wider European public um that then
benefits from the variety also of data
that we collect from the north from the
center of the European Union or from the
south thank you Petri a brief comments
yes short comments on on this issue um
I'm very glad we had excellent dialogue
today between commission Finland Sweden
and and for foresy
companies and as we
hearda very well understand the balance
we need forestry we need industry it's
part of our economy but uh it is also
part of future it's part of solution
it's not a problem but we we have to do
and we know how to do this forestry by
sustainable way there must be balance
between environment climate and Industry
and this is that we put more and more
attention in Finland and in Sweden and
as ol said the bioeconomy is also it's
it's a solution for our big challenges
new technologies how to how to get rid
of fossiles the bioeconomy is his
solution thank you please so second Road
Hing hi thank you president Oran and
prime minister thank you thank you
Christian thank you
Oro um uh about Ukraine and
um and also Orban how do you think that
um will use will uh Hungary lose their
right to vote to be able to keep on the
support for
Ukraine and also one question for
christon and orbo will you support uh
Ursula if
she'll uh decides
to uh continue as the president in the
EU commission thank
you would you bu starting yeah we have a
very uh clear um
engraved in um the treaties are very
clear rules on how to deal forward to
deal with um conflicting situation in
the European Union so and um first and
foremost the most important part is to
negotiate with each other and to find
compromises and we are working
intensively with the Hungarian
government on finding a solution that we
um have a solution by 27 for the Ukraine
uh 50 billion
uh Euros for the next four years this is
our main
priority U but but of course we also
prepare for alternative Solutions if
that is not something that we can reach
um but in general uh the the European
Union is built on dialogue and finding
Solutions together at with all member
states um the procedures that you were
alluding to which is the article 7
procedure is a different track um that
is enshrined in the treaties concerning
the right voting rights but this is
completely different from uh the
negotiations we have at the moment being
on the 50 billion alow me to say that uh
on the first question that we we
sincerely share the hope that 26
countries supporting Ukraine will become
27 countries when we meet uh uh February
1st uh uh um and on the other question
well let us uh all respect the fact that
only Ula can give the answer to her
potential candidacy but allow me to say
like this or repeat what I said
previously that we we have a very very
good experience of cooperating with Ula
as the president of the commission very
good it's very easy to
continue last question uh I think thata
you have done excellent work as a as a
leader of commission especially your
leadership within covid and Ukraine
crisis has been very very important and
I hope that in next commission this
leadership uh will continue but it is on
your hands um about
Ukraine the situation is is critical in
the war and in the
battlefield and Ukraine needs our help
we have to support Ukraine by militar
politically uh give humanitarian help as
long and as as much as needed and that's
why we we need it's crucial that we we
will have decision from next European
Council to support
Ukraine and we have to do this decision
I hope that with with 27 countries but
if it's not possible
when we have to decide it by 26
countries but now it's good that uh
there is
negotiations uh with Victor Orban and I
really hope that we can find a solution
we have to find the solution how to help
and support
Ukraine yes so for the last question uh
dog
industry you markook industry and
Industry I have a question for
Chron uh what are the most important
forestry issues for Sweden that you have
highlighted for Ursula fan and do you
feel that there is a scope in the EU to
take into account Sweden's special
nature when it comes to forestry
environment and climate issues well the
short the short answer is yes I think
there is a scope I think there is a
potential I I fully respect that all
countries don't think about forestry as
often as we do
fair enough not not very not very
strange I think we have underlined a few
things that forestry is it is partly a
carbon sink respect that growing uh
Forest forests are is a source of
biodiversity it is a source for new raw
material uh replacing fossils there is
enormous innovation in the industry all
of that has been underlined but also
just let us kind of acknowled that it is
a huge source of income huge source of
employment it's a huge source of the
rural economy in Sweden so it's actually
in a very in a very kind of
geographically special country it's very
very important not only for for the
money it brings and The Innovation but
also for providing a whole of the
country approach so I think we have
underlined all these aspects and we
fully respect that other countries
obviously can see it different and have
other experiences but this is a core
experience of Swedish industry so I
think we have made our case that doesn't
mean obviously that other countries
automatically change their mind of
course it doesn't work that way but in
the same way that other countries are
successful and and eager to to expose
their uh special interests or special
experiences Sweden we have to do that we
have to do that even more in the future
than we have done previously I think
it's important uh to emphasize again
that uh how much we
acknowledge that the importance of the
forests in the northern part of Europe
and here specifically Finland and Sweden
we all know that these forests are the
green lung of our climate we all know
also that they're the home of many many
people that you have a long tradition
living from the forest and with the
forest and there therefore a strong
incentive to cultivate to maintain and
to to Foster these forests and um this
is uh hundreds of years of experience
behind it where we as we discussed can
learn from each other and we can make
the best so that this knowledge is
available on the European level like you
of course also can benefit from the
knowledge for example of the Southern
forest trees or um Central forestries uh
in in the European
Union so thank you for joining us today
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank
[Music]
you